the Cluny twins have arrived  congratulations are in order for George  and Amal Clooney after two years of  marriage the couple welcomed their first  children together fully digested that  that there's two coming no and I don't  know how you fully digest that yeah but  I'm excited to be fun Petey spoke with  George in March about preparing for not  one but two new additions to their  family and the Clooney's famous friends  have offered up some parental advice for  the first-time parents over the last few  months ahead of welcoming their new  bundles of joy they're gonna be great  parents and you know it'll be it's gonna  be it's gonna be a huge challenge sleep  now cuz you won't be sleeping then  nobody's there with you at 3 o'clock in  the morning point here just go you you  get through it and you figure it out and  everybody does and it's a trial and  error and a whole lot of Tears  [Music]